dernière répétition hier matin sur le
terrain d'entraînement des girondins pas
de consignes particulières de dernière
minute mais plutôt une mise en condition
psychologique avant un grand rendez vous
une demi finale de coupe d'europe c'est
important mais avec le temps on vient
aussi l'expérience et c'est la force des
grandes équipes
chacun sait en fait ce qu'il a à faire
le plus difficile c'est surtout de se
concentrer sur sa propre vision des
choses et prendre dans sa tête
la mesure de son adversaire on est
confiant de de l'impossibilité de nos
forces et je crois que c'est ce qui nous
donne un petit peu une certaine sérénité
sans pour autant que ça aille au delà de
la limite permise
il faudrait c'est ne pas prendre de but
mais 1 0 je pense que ça peut être
suffisant on va essayer de montrer les
bus des mais surtout ne pas me prendre
mon crois qu'il faudra être très prudent
parce que c'est un système gros morceau
contre un masque ce qu'on veut dire
c'est un petit peu là la pointure du
torpédo salut équipe difficile à
manoeuvrer très physique et qui qui
profitera de la moindre occasion pour
nos contrées nul ne se hasarde bien sûr
un pronostic mais la conclusion nous la
garderons pour l'entraîneur aimé jacquet
je crois qu'il faut aborder le match
avec beaucoup plus de réflexion et je le
dis il y à quelques temps max fait dans
la tête plutôt que dans les jambes
demain soir